RONALD SMITH: Well, we
are now in the middle of a
section on global warming.
And we spent Friday looking at
how carbon dioxide levels have
changed in the atmosphere.
Are there any questions
on that before I go
onto the next subject?
So we have a pretty good idea
of how--what kind of carbon
dioxide is being emitted, how
much is being emitted every
year into the atmosphere.
How much of that is being
retained by the atmosphere.
How those levels are growing.
We'll come back to that either
at the end of this lecture or
on Friday when we talk about
projections into the future.
Part of the business of
projections is to compute what
the carbon dioxide
levels will be.
So we will return
to the subject.
Today I want to start off by
thinking of this recent period
the last 10,000 years called the
Holocene by geologists and
investigating what kind of
climate change there's been
during that period,
and whether that
would serve as a reference.
I doubt that there's
any perfect
reference for climate change.
It's been changing all through
geologic history.
But it's still worth I think
questioning whether or not the
Holocene might be a reasonable
choice as a reference for
looking at more recent
climate changes.
So I want to talk about that
to start with today.
And basically, we start the
Holocene with that last large
set of ice sheets retreating.
So the Laurentide ice sheet,
the Scandinavian ice sheets
retreating, the most rapid rate
of retreat was 12,000
years ago, 11,000 years ago.
By the time you got to about
8,000 or 9,000 years ago, most
of those ice sheets were gone.
And we're left with just the
big two that we have today
Greenland and Antarctica.
And then we're into what's
called the Holocene.
There was a period of relative
warmth called the Holocene
Optimum between 8,000
and 7,000 years ago.
And then much more recently
than that
Look, there's a time
notation shift.
When I'm talking about dates
that are more recent, I'll
shift over to the B.C.,
A.D. type of calendar.
So a lot of climate change is
talked about in terms of years
before present, but then at some
point, we switch over to
a more modern date notation.
So be aware of that switch.
So there was this period of time
centered on about 1,000
A.D. but lasting for a couple
hundred years called the
Medieval Warm Period.
After that, the Little
Ice Age came along.
I want to talk briefly
today about the
Year Without a Summer.
And then the curious
change in notation.
As the earth began to warm up
about 100 years ago when
climatologists studied this,
there was a kind of change of
attitude associated
with a change in
notation that was used.
And I'll talk about that
today, as well.
So first of all, then you've
seen this diagram before, I
think thousands of years before
present, coming out of
the last ice age, the heavy
curve is the average of a
bunch of different
glacial proxies.
And it's an anomaly.
So they've taken this period
through here as their
reference, and then everything
else is either colder than
that or warmer than that.
It's in degrees C, but not in
absolute degree Celsius.
It's not based on the
normal zero Celsius.
It's based instead on
taking this period
of time as a reference.
So coming out of last ice age,
slightly warm period.
Only a few tenths of
degrees warmer.
Than cooling off after
that as we get closer
to the present day.
And I mentioned this, as well,
that different authors will
plot this up in different ways
to make a different emphasis.
And in this case, they show some
of the outlier proxies to
give you a little stronger
sense of the
Medieval Warm Period.
But in this data set, they
showed that variation as a
grey background so you get
less of a sense of the
Holocene Optimum as being
an important feature.
Nevertheless, the data sets
are pretty much the same.
So the same data plotted just
with a choice of color
sometimes can give you a
slightly different sense of
what the climate's been doing.
So a word about this Medieval
Warm Period, then.
Historians seem to agree that
this was a fairly big deal in
Europe and in the Americas.
And it was a period when the
Vikings were able to leave
their homeland and travel west
across the Atlantic, setting
up villages, even farming on
the coast of Greenland.
And this is a dwelling left
from that period of time.
It was abandoned, of course,
when we got into
the Little Ice Age.
It became--the climate was
too cool to support those
settlements, and the Vikings
disappeared from that area.
It was also during that medieval
warm period, having
established these settlements
in Greenland, they were able
to then go the rest of the way
across the Atlantic and
establish brief residences
up in Newfoundland.
Hence the belief that really
the Vikings discovered
America, not Columbus.
They were there, well
almost 500 years
before Columbus came.
But again, taking advantage of
this warm period of time to
make that crossing.
Then came the Little Ice age.
1400 to 1800 roughly.
The historians will argue
forever about
what those dates are.
It's impossible to set
definite dates.
But a picture like this, a
painting by Bruegel from the
1500s gives you a sense
that it was a colder
period of time in Europe.
The Thames froze over.
A lot of the rivers in Europe
froze over that don't freeze
over today.
And that was recorded in many
different ways, not only in
art, but in many of the
economic and other
records of the time.
Right at the end of that, there
was a curious event
called the Year Without
a Summer.
The year was 1816 and this was a
big event both in Europe and
in the Northeast
United States.
There were several killing
frosts, at least one in each
of the summer months June, July,
and August. And so crops
that were planted died
in the frost,
replanted, were frozen again.
And so very little successful
agriculture was carried out in
the Year Without
a Summer 1816.
We think we know the
reason for that.
One year before of course, we
were just coming out of the
Little Ice Age.
Remember, this year could even
have been included in our
definition of the Little Ice Age
because it's so--the curve
is so wiggly, so it's hard to
know where to draw the end.
So this is right at the end
of the Little Ice Age.
But there was an event
that caused
that particular episode.
And that was Mount Tambora
in Indonesia, with a huge
volcanic explosion, putting
dust into the atmosphere.
A number of writers at the time
noted the red sunsets,
the very unusually red sunsets
from all that scattering
material in the atmosphere.
And as far as we know, that
was the largest volcanic
explosion since 180 A.D. So
it'd been more than 1,000
years since there'd been such
a large explosive volcanic
event on the earth,
as far as we know.
So that really was a
remarkable event.
Of course, what it does is put
dust into the stratosphere,
which increases the albedo
of the planet.
And if you remember, the formula
we derived for the
temperature of the planet that
formula that had the fourth
root of S times one minus the
albedo when the albedo is
larger, the planet cools.
So that formula probably doesn't
give us a quantitative
way to understand it, but at
least it shows qualitatively
that an increase in
reflectivity, caused by a
layer of dust in the
stratosphere,
would cool the planet.
The dust probably only lasts
three or four years, and then
the climate would quickly return
to normal after that.
The prices of oats rose from
$0.12 to $0.92, which gives
you an idea of how well
agriculture was doing.
And here in the USA, in New
England, which by that time
was pretty much continuous
agriculture if you drove
through New England, you found
very few trees at that time.
It was mostly just open
agricultural lands.
If you don't believe that, walk
through the forests of
New England today.
And as you walk on a trail,
every few minutes you'll come
across a stone fence, now all
deeply embedded in the
forests, which tells you that
150, 200 years ago all this
forest land was broken up into
open farmland at the moment.
And that was the case.
But then immediately after the
Year Without a Summer,
migration of farmers to the
West began to occur.
Not only because of this event,
but that's when new
lands are becoming open to
settlement in the Midwest, in
the Ohio Valley, for example,
where the soils were better
than in New England.
Because remember, the glaciers
had scraped all the topsoil
off of New England, but not in
the Midwest. There were large
areas where the glaciers did not
reach, and therefore they
had deep, high quality
top soils.
And when those lands become
available, that was the draw.
But the timing of these
migrations really
accelerated in 1817.
I know this from my own
family history.
Because the Smith family at that
point had been farming up
in Litchfield, CT for two
and a half generations.
And in 1817, they were gone.
They were headed west
to find new lands.
I'm sure that this had
a big role in that.
So this was a huge
event locally.
People doubt that it had much
of an influence in the
southern hemisphere because
by the time those volcanic
materials in the stratosphere
made their way into the
southern hemisphere their
density was pretty small.
But for a northern hemisphere
event, it was large.
And at that point, the
forest began to
regrow in New England.
So today New England in forest
covered, but at that point it
was farmland.
Another little interesting
footnote is that Yale
president Timothy Dwight
kept some of the best
daily weather records.
I haven't seen them myself,
but apparently they're in
Beinecke Library somewhere.
His daily hand written
temperature records throughout
that event are there, and if
you're a historian interested
in that kind of thing,
you might want to
go look those up.
Because he's got--we have
excellent records here from
New Haven on that event.
Any questions there?
OK, so the Holocene had many
small regional or temporary
climate events.
But generally, global
temperature--and as we saw
earlier, sea levels--varied
quite little during that
10,000 years.
So in that sense, it's probably
a pretty good reference.
Also but a lot was going on
in terms of human history.
Civilizations were rising and
falling during those 10,000
years, so we saw a lot of human
change in the way they
lived and structured their
societies in this relatively
constant period of time.
Perhaps it is the best reference
for later climate
change, but I think it's
quite open to argument.
I won't make the point
too strongly there.
Any questions about
the Holocene?
Yes.
STUDENT: You said that the
Little Ice Ages was mostly in
Europe and North America?
Why would it have
just been in--?
PROFESSOR: Well, let
me say this the evidence for
it comes mostly from those.
And of course, the evidence has
to do with where people
were living.
And we didn't have people making
written records of crop
prices and so on.
The Indians in the western
US weren't doing that.
There were other cultures.
So I hesitate to say that it was
only in Europe and North
America, but I hate to--I don't
want to make that point.
I think it's largely
an issue of record,
where we had good records.
But you can look for other
sources on that point.
But I think the main thing is we
only had good records from
Europe and North America.
So now we're going
to turn to this.
And you're quite familiar with
this kind of curve from the
data sets you've been plotting
up for the lab.
And starting in 1880, this shows
a temperature anomaly.
So again, a mean value perhaps
roughly here has been
separated out to make data
points earlier than 1940
appear negative, and ones after
that appear positive.
And it's curious because we seem
to have a roughly flat
period of climate.
Then a rapid increase
to the 1940s.
Then either flat or maybe
even a slight decrease.
And then a really rapid
increase since then.
And now very often you'll find
in the global warming skeptic
literature the point made and
it's a good one, but I'll
address it that the carbon
dioxide rise has been much
smoother than that.
OK, you get the annual cycle due
to uptake by forests and
oceans, but generally the
CO2 rise has been much
more smooth than this.
And so if the two are causally
related, why do the curves
resemble each other so poorly?
They're both rising, but they
have different structures.
I'll address that just a minute,
but we do want to come
up with some explanation for
this kind of irregularity in
the growth--
in the increase in temperature
during the 20th century.
And the total amount of
increase, if you go from, say,
minus 0.3, let's say, up to plus
0.5 or 0.6, that total
increase has been about
0.8.--0.7, 0.8,
or 0.9 degrees Celsius.
Something less than one
degree Celsius over
that period of time.
And as you know from the data
sets, when you combine the
land and the ocean, you wash out
the fact there's a pretty
big difference between
the land record
and the ocean record.
The land record is much noisier
and there's more
overall increase.
The ocean record is much
smoother less year to year
variation and less
trend with time.
So be aware that you're hiding
a lot of information when you
sum together these things.
There's extra information to
be gained by looking at the
continents and the oceans
separately.
The terminology I want to
point you to here I came
across this in the climatology
literature, reading books from
the 1940s and 50s where they
were commenting on this rise,
but they refer to it as quote,
"the recent amelioration of
climate."
What they were thinking
was they were aware of
the Little Ice Age.
That was already in
the literature.
They were considering this
warming to be a beneficial
thing because it was taking
us back to a more pleasant
climate coming out of
the Little Ice Age.
It wasn't till we got to about
1970 and 1980 that this new
term global warming
was coined.
And now, of course, that's
what's used to describe a
curve like this.
And there's a different
implication, though, isn't
there in those two terms?
Global warming suggests that
this is something that's maybe
a little unusual not just
returning to a more normal
state, but actually taking us
into a new kind of climate
zone we hadn't seen before.
And the word global in the
phrase global warming is a
little problematic I think,
too I mentioned it here
because I think it tends to
overstate the uniformity of
the warming.
If you look at the global
temperature trends 1979 to
2005, for example, which covers
basically this part
here so here it is at the
surface of the earth, and here
it is estimates for
the troposphere.
First of all, there's much more
warming on the continents
than over the ocean.
There's much more warming in the
northern hemisphere than
the southern hemisphere.
There's more warming
in the high
latitudes than in low latitudes.
So one danger in this term
global warming is that it
makes you think that the warming
is somehow uniform
over the globe, and that's
not the case.
If you had a 20 room mansion
kind of a silly analogy but if
you had a 20 room mansion and
you went to one of the rooms
and turned the thermostat way
up so that room became warm
and none of the others changed,
it wouldn't be very
useful or accurate to say,
well, that house
is now warmer inside.
It'd be true the average
temperature of all the rooms
has increased, but that's a
very poor description of
what's actually happened
when you've just
increased one room.
Well, that's too strong of an
analogy to apply to here
there's been warming
lots of places.
But I don't think you can say
that it's been globally
uniform, either.
So be a little bit careful, when
you hear this word global
warming, that there's a
lot of inhomogeneity.
The land warms more than the
ocean, the northern hemisphere
more than the southern
hemisphere.
It's a little more uniform
when you look up in the
troposphere, in the air in the
first 10 or 20 kilometers of
the atmosphere.
But still there's some
variation there.
And even some regions that
have cooled over
that period of time.
Questions on that?
So what else?
We talked a lot about carbon
dioxide, but what else may
have influenced the climate
of the 20th century?
These two large volcanic
explosions in our own era.
Forget about Tambora
back in 1815.
In the 20th century we had
these two large ones.
El Chichon in Mexico,
April, 1982.
There's a picture of it.
And Pinatubo in the Philippines
in 1991.
There's a picture of it.
That material, some of it
carried up into the
stratosphere.
The winds quickly carried it
around the globe only takes a
few days to get it distributed
around the globe and then
those dust particles stayed up
there for a couple of years,
and, as we'll see, did cause
a temporary cooling in the
climate connected with
those two things.
Here is from that same Mauna
Loa Observatory on the big
island of Hawaii where they
were measuring CO2.
They also measure atmospheric
transmission.
You have a telescope looks right
at the sun and measures
the intensity of the radiation
coming from the sun.
And when that dips, that's
usually because some dust has
come between you and the sun.
And notice these dips connected
with both El Chichon
and Pinatubo.
So we know that had an influence
on atmospheric
transmissivity, transmittance,
and probably on albedo, as
well, the fraction of
sunlight that was
reflected back to space.
The other big thing that
was going on along with
industrialization was sulfur
dioxide emissions into the
earth's atmosphere, mostly from
coal fired power plants.
Coal typically has quite
a bit of sulfur in it.
And when you burn coal with
sulfur, you produce SO2.
And the SO2 will often, after
it's been emitted, it will
react further chemically
to form small
particles, sulfate particles.
And those particles are a
primary source of air
pollution, a primary cause of
lack of visibility in the
atmosphere, and they reflect
sunlight back to space just
like those volcanic explosion
plumes would.
So that peaked in about
well, there are
various sources here.
This is organized
by continent.
And North America is the
maroon color here.
East and Central Asia I
think is the yellow.
But anyway, we all
were synchronous.
And it peaked in about 1880--
1980 or 1990 and then slowly
begin to decrease.
Not because coal was being used
less, but because by that
point, in the US first and then
in Europe, we had passed
the Clean Air Act.
And the Clean Air Act didn't
immediately shut down coal
power plants by no means did it
to do that but it required
that they put scrubbers on the
smokestacks to remove the
sulfate from getting emitted
into the atmosphere.
And we see that as
this beginning of
the decline in CO2--
SO2 emissions into
the atmosphere.
So we should watch for this
and see whether it has an
impact on the climate
of the 20th century.
So here's one of the it's not a
great way, but it's a pretty
good way to look at the
influences of these different
inputs into the atmosphere.
So these are model runs.
These are computer simulations
of climate done by a number of
different laboratories.
Every one of these curves
is a different
global circulation model.
One of these is at the
National Center for
Atmospheric Research.
The Department of
Energy has one.
NOAA has one.
The Germans have one.
There's one in the UK.
So many GCMs are in this
business of trying to model
climate and how it changes with
these different inputs.
The time scale is 1900
to about 2010 or so.
Temperature anomaly
is plotted.
Again, some period of time has
been used as a reference, and
that reference temperature
has been subtracted.
The different models are shown
in yellow, all the different
curves scribbled together.
The average of all the models
is shown in red.
And the observations, similar to
what I just showed you back
here, that is basically, with
that characteristic peak in
around 1940, is shown
in the black.
So how well do the models do in
predicting the climate of
the 20th century?
They don't get that peak.
They do, however, get the drops
in temperature connected
with Agung, El Chichon,
and Pinatubo.
But that comes through because
the modelers are putting in
those inputs into the model,
those increases in dust. They
also get the general
upward trend.
And they get this flat
period here before it
begins to rise rapidly.
So the models do pretty well
by putting in the CO2
forcings, the sulfate aerosol,
and the volcanic eruptions.
However, let's see how well
they do when some of these
things are left out.
By the way, this is from the
IPCC report, so this is
accessible to you easily,
these kinds of plots.
Here's the same set of models,
but they've put in natural
forcings only.
What does that mean?
That means the volcanic
eruptions are put in, but the
sulfate and the CO2
is left out.
Those are both anthropogenic.
So the model continues to
capture the drops connected
with volcanic input, because
that's included in what they
call natural forcing.
But it shows basically a flat
and even cooling climate after
1940, and missing entirely this
increase that was caused
well, the decrease here caused
by the sulfates, and then the
increase caused by the eventual
dominance of the CO2.
So I don't like models as a way
to prove things, but they
are--they do give us a clue
that these inputs are
important, and some of these
inputs are anthropogenic.
Questions on these curves?
I've included in the PowerPoint
presentation this
big legend which goes with
those last two curves.
If you're looking at it and want
to get the legend, you'll
find it there.
This is the same sort of thing
applied continent by
continent, global, global
land, and global ocean.
And in each case the blue
is models using
only natural forcings.
And the reddish one is models
using anthropogenic forcings.
And the difference is dramatic,
especially in
regards to this most recent
rise since 1975.
So the models seem to be giving
a consistent view in
that it's these anthropogenic
things, especially CO2, that's
causing the final rise there.
Are there questions
on these plots?
Yes.
STUDENT: I have a question about
the sulfur particles.
Do those increase the albedo of
the atmosphere before they
chemically react?
PROFESSOR: Well, yeah.
So the gas that's
emitted is SO2.
In the atmosphere they're
converted to sulfate particles.
And then that does put a haze
in the atmosphere that not
only limits your visibility
when you're trying to see
through the atmosphere, but
also reflects sunlight.
So that's the point.
It increases the albedo of the
earth, decreases the fraction
of the sun's radiation that is
absorbed by the earth, and
therefore cools the climate.
That's the idea behind this.
We think that's been responsible
for this decline
through here, partly masking
the effect of CO2 rise.
That's the curious thing.
It seems like one thing we did
to the atmosphere putting CO2
warmed the climate, another
thing we did putting SO2 in
has cooled the climate.
And for a number of years, the
SO2 actually won, or at least
the two were balancing
each other.
But now that we've begun to
decrease the SO2 input by the
Clean Air Act, now the CO2 is
dominant and the climate is
warming rapidly.
That's what we think is going
on for the 20th century.
It's curious, isn't it,
that these two things
balanced in that way?
Other comments or questions
on that?
OK.
So very short slide, then.
The factors that seem to have
the biggest influence on 20th
century climate.
The rise in carbon
dioxide level.
Sulfate emissions from
coal burning.
Major volcanic eruptions.
Oh, and I should have added
also heat storage.
Because as you saw from your
data, the oceans are warming
less than the continents, and
because the winds are
transporting heat back and forth
between the continents
and the oceans, the oceans are
probably limiting the rate of
warming of the continents
to some extent, as well.
The point is the oceans have
such a large heat storage
capacity that even though we're
doing these things to
the climate, in order to warm
up the earth, you've got to
warm up the oceans first. And
they have such a large heat
capacity that that's going to
limit the amount of heating
you can get because of that
heat storage effect.
That's going to give
you a lag.
Whatever you do that might cause
the temperature of the
planet to change, it's going to
be lagged because of that
enormous heat storage capacity
in the ocean.
One way to understand what's
going on over the last 100 or
so years is to look at the
radiative forcings.
This is, again, from
the IPCC report.
Radiative forcing is defined as
the excess radiation coming
down to the surface of the
earth over--since the
industrial revolution.
Let's say, over the last
100 or 150 years.
And it could be either
long wave forcing
or short wave forcing.
And here's how--we'll be coming
back and talk about
this diagram again.
It's a famous diagram you see
it often in arguments on
global warming.
But they give here, for example,
the radiative forcing
in watts per square meter caused
by the CO2 increase
over that period of time.
It's about 1.5 watts
per square meter.
That's a long wave
forcing, right?
So that's radiation from the
earth's surface gone up to the
atmosphere, been absorbed, and
been reemitted back down to
the earth's surface as thermal
infrared radiation.
That's that one.
There are some other greenhouse
gases that have
been increasing over that
same period of time.
It includes methane, N2O,
and some halocarbons.
And that is perhaps another
watt per square meter.
Ozone has been increasing
slightly in the troposphere.
Not as important as the others,
but maybe 0.3 watts
per square meter.
At the same time there have
been these aerosol effects
from the burning of coal, giving
sulfate particles in
the atmosphere.
And that's tended to cool the
climate significantly.
If you add all these up, you get
total net anthropogenic.
The greenhouse gases dominate,
but the aerosols
partly reduce this.
If I added up these three,
they'd be out to here or so.
Instead, the net's
only about 1.5.
So there's been a partial
cancellation between the
anthropogenic effects from
putting greenhouse gases into
the atmosphere and the
anthropogenic effects from
putting sulfate and aerosols
into the atmosphere.
Giving a net radiative forcing
over the last 100 years of
about one and a half watts per
square meter excess radiation
reaching the surface of the
earth, mostly in the form of
long wave infrared radiation.
Before we leave the subject of
the last 100 years, let's look
at some of the other things that
have been changing over
that period of time.
Sea level has been rising.
Not as rapidly as it did as we
came out of the last ice age,
but still rising.
The rate here is about three
centimeters per decade.
So every 10 that goes
by, we raise sea
level about that much.
It's been pretty steady.
And our estimates are that this
is approximately half due
to the melting of glaciers
putting more water into the
ocean basins, and the other half
is due to the warming of
the water that's already in the
oceans when you warm water
you make it expand, and so the
top of the ocean rises a
little bit because you've
increased the volume of the
existing water in the oceans.
So each has contributed about
half to this total increase.
Any questions on that?
Your problem set gave you a
couple chances to work out
some estimates of that.
There's another curious result
of the warming, of the CO2
addition, that I wanted
to point out you.
Adding CO2 to the atmosphere
increases
the greenhouse effect.
We know that.
It absorbs outgoing long wave
radiation and then re-emits it
back down to the surface,
causing a
warming of the surface.
But adding CO2 to
the stratosphere
does something different.
Because it's a greenhouse
gas, it can radiate.
And it tends to radiate more
energy to space than was going
on before you added
that extra CO2.
So the models tell us this.
We knew this was going
to happen.
But the data confirms that the
result of adding CO2 to the
atmosphere, while it warms the
troposphere and the surface of
the earth, it cools
the stratosphere.
This is sometimes referred to as
a line of evidence known as
fingerprint evidence.
In other words, if you change
CO2 and the models tell you
something about the nature of
that change like warming the
troposphere and cooling the
stratosphere and then you see
that happening in the
data, that tends to
confirm those theories.
Let's look at the data.
This is, again, with
a mean removed.
These are degrees
C departures.
The time schedule is from 1980
to 2010, and it's for
stratospheric temperatures.
And indeed, you find some sudden
warmings connected with
those volcanic explosions.
If you look at those two dates,
they correspond to El
Chichon and Pinatubo.
But generally there's been a
cooling of the stratosphere in
rough agreement with what the
models would predict for
adding CO2 to the atmosphere.
So if someone says, well,
we're not getting global
warming because the stratosphere
is cooling, well,
that's true.
The stratosphere has been
cooling over the
last 20 or 30 years.
But that doesn't negate the fact
that the troposphere and
the surface of the earth have
been warming over that same
period of time.
Another thing that I noticed
this fall and I commented on
it a few days ago it seems like
the leaves are falling
off the trees later and
later each year.
Here's a study that was
done in Indiana.
And they've got--
the year is plotted
on the x-axis.
1998 to 2008.
And on the y-axis is and this
one is the day of year.
DOY means day of year.
So January 1 is day one.
December 31 is day 365.
And it's a way to keep track of
where you are in the year
without using months and dates
and things like that, just a
straight day of year.
This shows two measures.
One is they measured the net
carbon uptake by this forest.
And the other is they looked
at the forest and gave it a
greenness index.
How green do the
leaves appear.
So here's the start of the
deciduous growing cycle.
Based on carbon uptake, it was
about year 115 or 118, and it
stayed relatively flat over
this decade of study.
According to the greenness index
it started a little bit
earlier, but it was also
flat during the 10
year period of time.
But if you look at the end, if
you look at the fall season
day of year 260, 280, 300
you see a real trend.
So the forests are keeping
their carbon uptake going
longer, their leaves aren't
changing from green to colored
until later, and that slope in
both ways of measuring it by
carbon uptake or by greenness
index is about
three days per year.
In other words, every year,
three days later.
That's an enormous change.
So that over the 10 year period
of study, there's been
about a 20 day --20 or
30 day delay in this.
And of course if you subtract
one from the other to get the
length of the growing season for
the trees, that has pretty
much the same trend as the fall
because the trend in the
spring is pretty small.
So that's a pretty dramatic
change in these mid-latitude
forests to see them extending
their green season so strongly
over the last 10 years or so.
Any questions on that?
So some of the observed changes
over the last--over
the 20th century.
Warming largest in the
northern hemisphere
continents.
Global warming of about
0.8 degrees Celsius.
Earlier in the course we've
talked about the arctic sea
ice reduction.
But remember, the antarctic
ice hasn't changed.
The antarctic sea ice
hasn't changed.
Most of the mountain glaciers
are in retreat.
We talked earlier about the
Greenland ice sheet
reducing its mass.
Sea level rise I showed
you that diagram here.
Stratospheric cooling,
and the deciduous
growing season is longer.
So all those changes have been
noted over the 20th century,
especially over the last
25 or 30 years or so.
Well, this has not stayed in
the scientific community,
these issues.
You read about global warming
today everywhere.
And I had great fun spent a
few hours over the weekend
pulling down current global
warming cartoons.
It's a whole genre now.
I mean, you could write
a PhD thesis about
global warming cartoons.
So, "remind me again why we
should care about global
warming."
Scientists have been accused of
jumping on a global warming
bandwagon and not being afraid
to say anything opposed to the
idea of global warming.
And this cartoon tends
to get that across.
The poor scientist here
being tortured.
Says. "OK, OK!
I believe mankind causes global
warming." And, "very well.
Give him back his
research funds."
So the idea was that there's
somebody out there that was
insisting that we all believe in
global warming in order to
get our research funded.
Which I don't think has been the
case, at least not to my
knowledge and experience.
Then what should
we do about it?
This guy is saying,"
well, it's great.
You just tell this guru how much
pollution your company is
responsible for, and he tells
you how many trees you have to
plant to atone for it." So
that's an easy way out of the
global warming problem.
What's this one?
Yeah, the universal excuse.
So it used to be the dog
ate my homework.
Now its global warming.
Whatever problem you're
confronted with, just blame
global warming.
"Global warming does seem harder
and harder to deny."
Where the polar bears are
sunning and the seals are
playing volleyball.
"So these scientists did this
experiment that if you drop a
frog into boiling water,
he jumps out.
But if you put him into warm
water and heat it slowly, he
just swims around until he's
cooked." "Well, what's the
point of that experiment?" And
the final frame says, "beats
me." "Scientists, go figure."
"Probably the same ones
studying global warming." And
there we all are in this
gradually warming
bucket of water.
And this is in the New York
Times this morning.
This is the current one.
It's called "Happy
Climate Change
Denial Season." "Yee-haw!
It's snowing.
Time to deny global warming."
And I'll let you
read the rest of those.
We're out of time for today,
but we'll continue this
discussion next time.
So we're finished.
I'll leave that up there.